situated near a busy intersection in
Munich Schwaben district is a world war
2 bunker it is under a preservation
order the bunker was built in 1943 to
protect up to 700 people during air
raids now it's one of Munich's most
unusual residences hello hi I'm Stefan
Hagemeyer I'll show you around
Stefan Hagemeyer is a real estate
developer he lives right at the top of
the bunker in an apartment spread over
three floors he has four hundred square
meters of space the furnishings reflect
a mix of styles playful elements provide
a contrast to the cold a steer look of a
bunker Stefan Hoover Meyer has
deliberately left the building's
original structure exposed in some
places the first time I came in here I
found it quite oppressive the walls are
2 meters thick and none of the seven
floors had an opening to the outside
that's not something you normally
experience usually at some point there's
light air and a view of the outside so
the first thing he did was to have one
window cut into each wall for windows
per floor when Stefan Hagemeyer bought
it in 2010 this is what the bunker
looked like without windows 14
construction workers spent nearly seven
months cutting the openings into the two
meter thick concrete
we took out 2,000 tons of concrete for
the openings roughly the weight of 2,000
trucks it was quite a challenge
but that wasn't the only one there was
also the question of how to approach the
whole idea of turning a building from
the Nazi era into a place to live how
does one leave a link to the past and
leave that history visible while at the
same time making it comfortable and cozy
the whole combination has to work
somehow a staircase leads up to the
newly built top floor adding a penthouse
also meant cutting through the bunkers
thick concrete roof so now we're finally
on top of the bunker there's a fantastic
view from here the dining area is here
in the living room which is absolutely
flooded with light on one side you have
a cemetery with a sea of trees that
merge into the English garden with the
English and garden force mills
[Music]
I'm fresh one one clear days you can see
the Alps the penthouses rooftop terrace
provides a 360 degree view of munich in
a clear not to his Bavarian roots and to
protect visitors from the wind or the
Sun Stefano gamaya has even installed a
traditional dining niche made of pine
Steffan Hagemeyer and his companies
spent five million euros converting the
bunker into a modern usable building the
26 meter tower includes apartments and
office space it also houses gallery
called vnk are the gallery regularly
hosts exhibitions with a focus on art
and architecture the shows are open to
the public free of charge that was very
important to the owner the banco
frontier for decades the bunker just
stood here in this part of the city
it was very conspicuous and quite creepy
and unpleasant and so I think it's
important that the public can now come
in and see how the building has been
reclaimed for peaceful purposes divided
by three that would have at home in a
bunker with much effort and money this
ghost of Munich's past has been
transformed into a veritable showpiece